It's necessary, isn't it? Isokawa tilts her head a bit.
That girl doesn't seem to have the will to fight back, but it doesn't seem like she's
just trying to run away blindly.
I think it's a
flower, yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah, it
doesn't hit
me. I don't have to throw it.
The rules of this competition are only written by paper balloons using the specified soul,
that is, in my hand.
On the other hand, if Misaka Mikoto tries to do something about the ball and fires an electric shock at her, she will be attacked with her ability, so she will
be disqualified or
something.
]
If we don't change our long swords, we'll
lose our lives just by getting the
same tan.
It took some time to create this situation.
Usually, weak electromagnetic waves are emitted around Mikoto Misaka, and
if the person is conscious of it, it will play the role of a radar.
It's almost impossible to get close
to them, but I'm concentrating on the players who have their abilities blocked by the rules of the game, and in
this situation, I
'm
Jager.